Jess Herbst mayor of New Hope Texas do I
have that right absolutely right thank
you thank you Jess for being on the
program so we've been talking about this
issue today a lot about the transgender
issue you know first off for people who
don't know so this is in in New Hope
Texas a small town about 600
some-something people it's an older
manic system of government correct
that's correct that's correct one mayor
in five aldermen okay so how is the how
did you become mayor than for people who
aren't maybe aware of the process okay
well I was I've been an alderman since
2003 it was up for my re-election as
Alderman last year at this time I've
also been mayor pro-tem for the since 2
2013 I was running the mayor was running
the mayor died three days before the
election was held he's still won so that
left the Town Council with no mayor in
our particular type of town we're a
class-b town under Texas general law ok
the City Council appoints a new mayor
they nominated and voted for me
unanimously so I've been mayor ever
since ok and I want to be clear but now
you were an alderman before but that was
as Jeff Herbst correct that's correct
that's correct they did not know me yes
the council didn't know me it's just
until last November and the town did not
know me as jest until February 1st so
can you still put it on your resume at
that point what are the rules with that
I think so yeah it was the same warm
body okay all right I don't know I don't
know what the rules are so listen um
obviously this is a hot-button issue
right now you've been very outspoken
you've been upset about the bathroom
bill Donald Trump has kicked this back
to the states and in Texas they want
people to use the bathroom according to
their biological sex why do we have a
problem with that well let's see because
do you want me in the bathroom with you
and do you want trans men in the
bathroom with your wives and girlfriends
you know we've been using the bathroom
since the dawn of time it's never been a
problem until somebody had an issue and
the whole bathroom bills a smokescreen
anyway that's really not what this bill
is about this bill is about taking the
rights of the city to make
anti-discrimination
away from them the only reason that they
want to do this city Plano city of
Dallas City of Austin several cities in
Texas just like Charlotte North Carolina
and pass their own anti anti LGBT
discrimination laws they say you can't
discriminate Austin doesn't want that
they want to have that control for
themselves
same thing with North Carolina North
Carolina passed that bill not for
bathrooms they were upset because
Charlotte had passed their own
anti-discrimination bill and they wanted
to control it and if you were a
legislator and you wanted to say hmm
we're gonna use the state to take the
city's rights to pass their own
individual ordinances away from them
would you tell people that would just
say hey we're here to pass a bill to
take your rights as a city away
no you wouldn't get you wouldn't get two
inches with it so what you're gonna do
is make them afraid you're gonna say hey
let's come up with an issue like
transgender people people will be afraid
of that and that you can beat the drum
around that and people who don't
understand transgender people are just
automatically afraid it was like oh my
god they're weird there's something
wrong with wanna say what if what if
they're not afraid what if they just
disagree what if they just disagree and
they think you know because because
gender has no basis in biology about sex
I'm just saying shouldn't you allow for
room that maybe someone can just
disagree and not be afraid or not be
discriminating they just disagree and
they think the person the last time you
were in the stall in the bathroom yes
you know what was between the legs of
the person the stall next to you you
know what we're not just talking about
the stalls we're talking about the
common areas and that's that's beside
the point of again this is an idea there
are major institutions in the United
States that are that revolve around sex
you know higher education when you talk
about scholastic programs bathrooms are
a portion of that and there is a
legitimate argument legitimate grievance
from people particularly parents who say
okay bathrooms but now we see with
sports with this girl who's
transitioning into a boy who just won
eight well in your state a Texas state
wrestling title there's no basis in
biology for gender compared to sex and
if someone says that is that hateful
well no but that's not actually - there
is basis in biology there have been
quite a few studies that show that
there's a distinct difference in the
Briant of a transgender individual then
there is an assistant or individual so
there is a basis in biology there is
something different about us we didn't
wake up in the morning go gee I think
we're gonna do this this is something
you were born with
you live this way your whole lot as far
as the I'll disagree with you there we
can go back to it but I'll disagree with
you there and I have scientific studies
in front of me again keeping respectful
just disagreeing I want to make sure we
allow for disagree more someone who is
not afraid or think someone's wired it's
ok ok you are you are confusing SB six
with the president's guidance the
guidance deals with schools and you're
right when you get to a locker room
where there's open areas there needs to
be some concession made there to make
sure that people aren't looking at other
genitals but sv6 has nothing to do with
locker rooms it has to do with public
bathrooms sure and again you know I
don't want to know what the gender or
what the what the what's between the
legs of the person next to me assault I
just want to go in it P and then come
out I've been doing it for years I've
never heard it well I put that but the
onus is on you at that point because
there are people fort for a long time
people been going to the bathroom that
is assigned by their biological sex
there is biological sex it's not a
social construct that exists and most
people are uncomfortable with changing
that they want to go into the bathroom
with biological women or biological
males that's that's the issue so it
doesn't matter if you just want a piece
oh do they they just want a piece so it
comes down to the issue science not
about feelings you know one thing the
major the biggest study that's been
conducted I have the abstract right here
prior to cross sex hormone treatment no
differences in brain volumes between
transsexuals and comparison subjects
were found the changes only happened we
put it in a in a controlled clinical
trial study after across hormone
replacement therapy now again we're just
getting it a sense this doesn't mean
that you can't make your own personal
decisions on how you want to live your
life but enforcing them upon people who
disagree and they disagree on a
scientific basis is why I think this is
such a hot-button issue yeah but you're
looking you're citing one study there
are several other studies that show
something completely different there's
there's not a whole lot of studies on
transgender they didn't even get the
word didn't even come about until the
70s that's right and there are just
there are just as many studies that show
that yes there's brain differences
before cross-sex hormones and there says
it so they don't happen it just depends
on which study you look at and who
you're listening to the point of the
matter is people really don't know why
we're transgender and the thing is if
you don't know that the person next to
you is transgender why do you care why
do you want because we do know what
their sexes so for I'm going on you
don't know you do know what their sex is
you yeah biological sex can be
scientifically determined I'm not
talking about going in and having
mirrored shoes looking at everyone's
that you know looking at everyone's who
has or doesn't have you know because of
how you how you were born so with a male
or female and that's the rule set lower
just like you have to if you go to an
all-male school if you go to an
all-female school if you get to compete
on the female track team if you guess I
competed on a male's wrestling team it's
you're a male or a female I'm sorry but
if you know the biological sex the way
somebody was born as some but of a
perfect stranger in the bathroom next to
you you're doing something wrong there's
there's something wrong with what you're
doing you should know what that person
has between their legs the winner and
pee leave them alone it it's not no
one's not leaving them alone this is
again this is about this is about the
institution and the idea of sex of
biological sex it's just about the idea
you think you know what I am so
therefore you're gonna get upset about
let me give you example here in Texas
biologically you are a man that's not an
insult biologically you are a man your
sex is male we're not worried about you
said you think you know who I am so I'm
just saying that yes biologically you
are a male you so in Frisco not too long
ago a man saw what they thought was a
transgender woman going into bathroom he
went in the bathroom drugged her out and
assaulted her she just happened to be a
big girl bit masculine yeah and they get
the short end of the stick big girls
because they don't get the benefit out
by the way that's abhorrent totally
unacceptable
totally unacceptable but it's anecdotal
it's now what we're talking about well
it is because you're saying you're
saying that I'm gonna know the sex of
somebody that's not me
you've seen Laverne Cox what what
bathroom does chigan is what you know if
you didn't know if you didn't ask if you
didn't look you wouldn't know if you
didn't know it wouldn't be a problem
that's the whole point we've been doing
this we mean you can go to the bathroom
with transgender people you're whole now
that's not true you can tell it is true
we can hand Jess respectfully I can tell
okay I don't once for two years I'm 50
years old I'm not that good trust me
there are people you can't tell there
are lots of people you rent and that
will first and you've been going through
the bathroom wisdom see the problem is
is that it's not it's not the people
that are at we hate to use the term
passable it's the people like me that
are not passable right that freaks you
out well then that contradicts your idea
that you would never know
again that's the issue that people do
know and people who people since the
beginning of time who agree on this
biologically determined idea of sex
don't want to upend it because of a
political movement of gender I don't
think that's right
that's not really okay see okay tell me
one bathroom what gender bathrooms did
there were not men and women bathrooms
until about the 1890s before that there
were no women bathrooms
most societies going back to the end of
time have had multiple genders
transgender is something that has been
accepted in cultures since the beginning
of time it wasn't until the modern age
that things started changing look that's
not it's not entirely accurate people
who were see I mean you can talk about
eunuchs you can talk about man servants
you can talk about people who have I
acted as an amoeba filling the role that
was determined for them at the time
which I don't necessarily think is a
good basis for our current society but
our current society right now in the
modern world we recognize sex
biologically the onus is on someone else
who wants to up end that because of a
political movement based on gender and I
don't believe that anyone made a
convincing argument I don't and I don't
think there's anything wrong with a
state or a city saying you use the
bathroom that applies to your sex there
is no biology for the basis of gender
and how someone identifies or feels why
are you so worried about my biology why
does my biology why is it your business
why does it everybody else's business I
don't go in and go gee let me see your
biology I want to make sure that you
live up to the standard of being a man
sure ask you that why are you asking me
why is it why is it your business yeah
what I am I'm gonna walk in the bathroom
I'm gonna sit down in the stall I'm not
gonna bother you when I get finished I'm
gonna wash my hand and I'm gonna walk
out sure how does that hurt anyone okay
how did it affect anyone can it come and
you can I answer your question okay well
I've seen some of your tweets I've seen
some of your profiles and what you're
doing you do assume some ulterior mode
of your opposition sometimes that it's
hateful that they find people scary that
if they disagree it's discrimination so
first off that matters because it's
framing an argument a scientific
argument in as an opinion of one it's
taking as we saw Chris Cuomo saying it's
about the science well let's talk about
the science it's about acceptance so
that's my issue there it is and then it
well it's either about the science or
acceptance it can't be about both and
then my issue after that is again we are
talking about the institution of the
idea of male and female biologically
determined we see this with the wrestler
case right now we start with Fallon Fox
a male who became a female and beat the
crap out of women we see that now we see
professors who are perhaps being drawn
up for hate speech charges from
misgendering their students we see it
with uh with with a WNBA has different
standards from the Olympic Committee
there needs to be a set standard of what
is a male and female and people are
saying now and I think there's more push
back than ever because of the LGBTQ AI
community trying to blur the lines where
people are saying well cyan't let s go
back to basic biology and that's why
okay and I understand where you're
coming from and it is by the a very
solid belief that you haven't a lot of
people do that that gender and sex if
you want to use sex they're different
yes binary you are only a male or only a
female yet everything in the world
nothing in the world is binary um
there's not night and then instantly day
there's Twilight in between and there's
the same thing with people in our minds
we are somewhere in between and there's
people that are far more one-way than me
I'm sort of in the middle sure it's not
a binary world that we're trying to be
fitted to because we've had in your mind
but that's not the physical and
biological world they're not the same
thing it's either about the science or
acceptance and you said about you talked
about the science as Chris Cuomo doesn't
then when we want to talk about the
science you then say well it's not about
the scientists about in our minds and I
think that's imperious it is the science
of our mind it is our brains that make
us this way and the science shows that
there's a difference ever and there's a
reason we feel this way we don't do this
by choice this is the way we've always
felt and there's more to it than just
the bathroom that you're not
understanding no that's what I'm
bringing up about it's about color it's
about the entire idea of male and female
that's why the bathroom issue matters
especially when in New York City you can
sue a landlord for calling you a he will
actually know a landlord
in Texas can kick me out for being
transgender with no ramifications I can
lose my job you can kick me out for not
supporting your opinion as a transgender
that's the meaning of freedom no yeah
actually no yes against that yes he
cares no protection there's no
protection for me whatsoever you are
protected you can't get you can't get
thrown out of your apartment for your
opinion try again just this ridiculous
raise you can sue but you consume and
you can win I cannot there's no protect
that is the opposite of the trees yes no
it's not it's just respectfully I can
Texas as a note is a note you know it's
a no-fault state in that sense you can
fire anyone for any reason you can evict
anyone for any reason my parents had it
when they first moved to Texas they were
in a townhome and the neighbor it was it
was one of these you know community
areas in Texas and their neighbors dogs
were crapping on their lawn they
complained to the the landlord saying
listen their dogs are crapping on their
lawn they happen to be friends with
those people they said well you're out
because we allow them to crap on your
lawn in Texas they can do it for any
reason with any person regardless of
LGBTQ that's just reality that yeah that
was an HOA and y'all wasn't naturel HOA
agreement the Texas Texas law allows you
to evict Texas law allows you to fire
without cause period where's in New York
you can sue a landlord because it's now
law if they misgender you do we can we
agree that that's absurd I don't know
that that's true so I'll take your word
for it let's say I misgendering you
let's say I say Jeff let's say I say he
or something should you have the right
to be able to sue me or consider that
hate speech so you said you've read some
of my blogs you know how I feel about it
right you've been through my blog do you
understand what I've said I don't care
what you call me right it's not a big
deal to me you can call me anything you
want but I'm time about the right is is
that a fundamental right to be referred
to as a pronoun as someone demands do
you have the right to infringe upon
someone else the language they must be
anything other than what the person
around it wants to you it doesn't mean
you have to like that it doesn't mean
that that person is a decent human being
for doing it but no you don't have I
don't have the right to have to force
you to call me anything okay if you want
to call me Fred for the rest of the
interview you can that's your rock I
won't I don't want to be disrespectful I
want to disagree with others name is
Fred doesn't make you feel good okay
good listen if we talk about the brain
issue a the science doesn't I don't have
a sense in front of me I would respect
that but you know you look at we talk
about this 98% of confused boys and 88%
of confused girls eventually except
their gender puberty that now that you
can say all you want but that is just
pumping up the issue confused we're not
confused I don't know who I am you think
I would do this do you think I would
give up white male privilege to do this
if I was confused no but I do think you
could be confused just like I just like
I think I was confused when I when I had
I wore lady jeans and had long bangs at
one point cuz I thought it looked cool
just like people who are MC Hammer pants
I'm not saying you are confused but I
allow for the possibility that you could
be you could be you know just as I could
be confused I could look back on this in
20 years and say you know and I was
totally wrong and could be it's a little
different than just saying these people
are well statistically statistically
they are that's the issue I want to get
to statistically when you look at 98% of
confused boys yet 98% of boys end up
going back to their gender eighty-eight
percent of girls when you look at the
suicide rates where are you getting
these statistics where do you get the 98
percent of boys and why are you calling
the most the statistics and I'm bringing
up we're talk about studies and you talk
about you're talking about people who
were born a woman but they are a trans
man right we're talking about yes the
teenage we talk about teenagers we're
talk about teenagers who are often
encouraged right now by the trans
community to come out as we saw with the
wrestling case who then end up reverting
back to their biological sex
many do and then if you want to talk
about where I'm getting my statistics
PubMed from that previous study right
now this is from the Williams Institute
you know 41% of obviously trans people
you know this you've talked about this
attempt suicide and the numbers don't
get better after the surgery so could we
not cut someone that no no that's that's
where they're wrong the numbers do get
much better after the surgery the the
Susan Wright drops drastically surgery
this is incorrect with your incorrect
your your figure this is incorrect and
this is why most medical establishments
won't do the surgery because it's too
high restroom oh the vast majority of
medical professionals and psychological
professionals agree that transgender
people should be treated as a gender
that they identify with there's a minor
group they're not even really doctors
they have the doctors in their name
they just say that they're just a hey
this is totally totally false I'm sorry
it's totally false for the people the
left or people who consider themselves
pro science biological sex is determined
every single medical field that involves
human biology or animal biology it
revolves around this the first thing
they do if they're taking notes if
they're checking Turtles they lift up
the shell and say male or female the
first thing you do when you go into a
doctor's they say male or female and if
you say identify as a female but you
still have a penis they're going to
treat you as a male they're going to
treat the same symptoms as that of a
male that doesn't change regardless of
opinion and to say that they're not
doctors a silly well I said they're not
doctors because the people who published
these studies the people are behind a
lot of these things are not doctors
they're just behind in behind a hate
group that calls themselves the American
medical John Hopkins so sheer hate group
yeah John Hopkins because those people
were the guy who published that if you
go back and look John Hopkins has
disavowed any it they're not standing by
here behind that guy they're saying that
he is not representing John Hopkins and
his opinion does not represent John
Hopkins for being okay and you know
you've looked at that doesn't matter
they don't perform the surgery okay go
ahead and ask a question another
question of you what do we do that
intersex people welcome you're talking
about a very very small percentage of a
percentage point so we don't change the
entire societal structure because what
do you do just throw them away they
don't count they're not no one's saying
throw them away again you're gonna be
you're appealing to an emotional
argument this is not a biological
argument so make an exception we make an
exception for intersex pee it's a
biological okay so how are you gonna
Terman there how we're going determine
where the intersex people go once they
once they once they are grown up and
they are determined to be male or female
by a medical professional again we go
into medical profession but they're not
it's not to abortion what if it's about
wrote if it's about rape or incest to us
right but such a small percentage point
it's not relevant at the point and
that's not what you're arguing as far as
law and you have the ability to enact
law so I want to talk about the law and
the subjects you keep talking biology go
ahead an intersex person biologically is
both biologically they have
characteristics of both genitalia
what do you do about them I just
answered you said you make an exception
right I said we won't yeah I just answer
the questions I'll give you that it was
a white what you said you'll wait until
we determine what sex they are but
they're not they're both sex
they are both the vast majority of
intersex intersex people end up living
as one sex only because at birth the
doctor makes a determination no no no
actually not actually new surgery no and
there's a big MOOC what about it it's a
there's there's not a big movement
because of all intersex people in entire
world got together it couldn't be a big
movement so let's entirely statistically
false it's worn out of several thousand
people I don't know the number in front
of me so I'll work off of that right now
but even if it's 100 which is not
accurate just as it's not just about one
man John Hopkins it's about the actual
medical establishment let me ask you
you've been open about your across from
own sex replacement therapy so if the
question is too personal you do not have
to answer it but I do have a follow-up
which I believe is relevant have you
gone through the the bottom half surgery
no okay you have not so when you go to
the doctor does it do you go to an
ob/gyn No so your doctor isn't a GP no
my doctor to the female does your doctor
check your testicles testicular health
yeah there's nothing I'm not saying this
consult you so again his doctor is
treating you as a male well she also
treats my breasts and has me getting
mammograms does your doctor do that for
you
it was because I didn't add artificial
breasts that are non-functional they're
they're not artificial they are
functional they're artificial yes
they're not real breasts you added them
they I did not add them they grew they
re hormone replacement therapy that's
correct yes exact injection of
artificial hormones by the way I was oh
go ahead
they're not they're not injected and
they're not artificial every person male
or female has estrogen and testosterone
yep at at puberty the levels of those to
change all I've done is adjust mine so
that when I went through puberty if they
had gone to more estrogen testosterone
that's where I am now
my body responded those natural hormones
the same way anybody would come on
as far as natural you and your natural
state do not have breasts it's just like
Barry Bonds in his natural state did not
hit the homerun record he took chemical
and hormonal enhancements let's not get
into the workplane my point is your
doctor still your doctor doesn't hate
you and your doctor has to treat you as
a biological male my doctor treats me as
a transgender individual my doctor
respects my father has been fantastic
it's not about respect I respect you as
a person I respect you as an individual
it's not about respect I'm talking about
technology but they don't they treat me
as a person who is transgender that is a
thing it can be it does not have to be
just male or just female and that's the
thing that is that's really the sticking
point okay if you didn't artificially
inject hormones you would be just male
you know that and I know that your
doctor knows that if you did not inject
hormones would be just male anything
absolutely nothing you don't go through
hormonal therapy okay so how did you
perform on replacement therapy the same
way my wife does we after swim in halls
she wears the exact same patch I do for
estrogen because her estrogen levels are
low so she gets under bring hers up my
estrogen levels are low for who identify
us so I were the same type of patch to
bring money so I misuse the word
injection if not through the infusion of
artificial hormones you would be a man
just as I and that's it's not mindful of
my point but why do you call them
artificial that makes it sound like it's
some sort of these are not hormones that
would ever occur naturally in your body
in its natural male State it's like
saying cyanide is natural hemlock is
natural yeah but you shouldn't have a
Miss bobbye's you don't know because you
don't have a normal level of cyanide in
your body I have a natural level of him
actually we do a lot of it and so do you
not hemlock but okay you have you have
estrogen in your body I absolutely know
that and the ratio is actually about 12
to 15 times more we just talked about
that in the previous segment that's why
this girl should not be allowed to
compete against women and wrestling it's
not fair again and now again to the
institution of sports there there's a
reason that sex has mattered there's a
reason that people have been divided by
the way it's a huge part of the feminist
movement they wanted to define the the
sexual lines the sexual differences
between male and female they
celebrated them and because of that now
with this attempt to destroy these lines
with a made-up non-scientific term of
gender my point is you can live your
life however you want however people who
disagree with you are not hateful they
are not science deniers they are
actually science acknowledges if that's
the word acknowledges of science and a
state and a city has the right to make
that law and most people don't don't
want their daughters going into the
bathroom with people who are
biologically men and that's perfectly
reasonable that's all it's not
reasonable because there has never been
any instance of a transgender person
ever causing any problems ever having
anything in any bathroom anywhere you
know you can't find me any interest but
tell me how many it says have there been
of men regular men sports men I'm a man
I do that go into bathrooms and molest
plenty there's never been a transgender
that did that ever and you know that
because people not sure we actually
wrote about it on the website and
actually ironically enough occurred in a
target yeah but again we're getting into
the anecdote way that target person was
not a transgender that was a person that
was just trying to bring this whole
thing up they were not transgender how
do you determine though that if in two
months time I say I'm a woman how do you
determine that I'm not why can't I go
target target target because two months
after that if you're back to being a man
you're not transgender that's not true
what about what if you know what if what
if I'm gender-fluid that's a big thing
now you support gender fluidity I do
yeah I'm dunder fluid so what's to stop
me from using any restroom I want really
that's how you behave if you're gonna be
a decent human being and you go and then
you do the bathroom and come back out
who cares if you can use any bathroom
you at one point you said that person
wasn't transgender you have no
definition as to what it really is
that's how you behave in a moment where
that part that person admitted they
weren't transgender that person admitted
that we're doing that but there's
nothing to stop anyone from doing that
so you either have to determine it by
science or by feeling or sidetracking
the issue the fact that there has never
been on a legal record of an actual
transgender person attacking someone and
MS whole thing is built on the fact that
we're gonna hurt so
when there were perverts that force
every now just said no no what my little
don't you said I don't want my daughter
going in there why yeah why because I
don't want to deliver a biology lesson
when she comes out which I think the
transgender community would serve well
to listen if you if you see what's
between my legs when you're going to the
bathroom and you let your daughter see
what's going on every five legs y'all
are doing the bath no but like you said
it's the barely passable so let me let
me says respectfully Justin I want to
have you back on the show if my if a
daughter goes in and sees you in the
restroom guarantee you she's gonna come
out to Daddy and have some questions you
can guarantee that but I've been to the
bathroom for the last eight years around
here I've been in the bathroom with
little girls big girls women all kinds
of things and nobody's ever had any
questions you've been a transgender from
eight years you said it was just a
recently I had I have been transitioning
for two years but I have been you don't
just this is not it this is not I just
decided this yesterday
it takes a long yes but no girl would
have a question no girl would have a
question about Jeff they would have a
question about Jess and that's again
what we're deciding to or deciding to
convince were deciding to make people
uncomfortable everyone else ninety-nine
point whatever percent of society or a
very small percentage who screamed the
loudest and it's not based on biology
and my point is the people who scream
the loudest go ahead before I started
transitioning before I started taking
hormones before I went full-time yes I
I stood up here six years trying to
figure out if I could do this if I can
survive in society if I could go out and
be myself in society and function
without you know the Frankenstein crowd
of pitchforks and torches it took a
while but I figured so yes I've been
living under the bathroom as yes for
probably six years and never won through
there been an incident never once has
there been a little girl kids mer fact
since I've come out and since I've
explored the world you know who has a
problem with us people who are over the
age of 40 the kids kids could care less
kids think it's perfectly fine the
younger they are the easier their
understands they're not scared the kids
aren't scared sir parents that are
freaked out I don't know if that's
entirely accurate but let's go that we
do have to end this interview let me
leave it with this I would never
condone anyone being hateful mistreating
you abusing you or physically assaulting
you I hope that people treat you well to
help your town is happy with you and you
serve them well as mayor but I also
still agree that people should use the
bathroom too which applies their
biological sex I hope we can agree on
that and hopefully you can come back on
the show and we can have more productive
discussions hey if you like this clip
you're like most of the internet you
have a short attention span but it was
taken from the full show you can see it
in the box playing next to me that's
once a week on Thursdays full one and a
half hour show or you can join the Mudd
Club for the daily show we have to take
some of that off YouTube because they're
monitoring us and censoring our words